[Música]
la corte constitucional de Guatemala
ordena revisar los resultados de la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
generales del pasado domingo Sandra
Torres y Bernardo Arévalo podrían no ser
quienes concurren en el balotaje
presidencial de agosto
nueva polémica en Twitter elon musk
enciende la red social con el anuncio de
que va a limitar el número de
publicaciones que los usuarios podrán
ver al día sin embargo la restricción
exacta no está Clara
en Canadá a miles de trabajadores
portuarios van a la huelga al no poder
renovar el convenio colectivo la
movilización sindical centrada en
Columbia británica espera tener un
fuerte impacto en la economía del país
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
maceo y es para mí un gusto acompañarnos
empezamos en Guatemala porque la corte
constitucional ordenó la revisión de los
resultados de la primera vuelta de las
elecciones generales del pasado domingo
por lo tanto podría cambiar el nombre de
los candidatos que se enfrentarán en la
segunda vuelta prevista para el mes de
agosto de momento estos dos candidatos
recordemos son la centrista Sandra
Torres de la une y el socialdemócrata
Bernardo Arévalo del movimiento semilla
nos amplía nuestro corresponsal Andrés
Suárez esto ocurre luego de la
impugnación de un conglomerado de nueve
partidos políticos que impugnaron los
resultados ante la Corte constitucional
dentro de estos partidos políticos se
encuentra el partido vamos de el actual
presidente Alejandro yamatei el partido
cabal de edmon mulet y el partido valor
de sur y ríos estos candidatos que tanto
sonaron y que uno de los dos
presuntamente por las encuestas podría
llegar a pasar a segunda vuelta pero que
esto no ocurrió para estos partidos
políticos nueve de ellos en Guatemala
ocurrió un fraude electoral Y entonces
el tribunal supremo electoral a partir
de este sábado deberá realizar un nuevo
reconteo de la cerca de 24.000 mesas de
votación 3500 centros de votación
solamente recordemos que Sandra Torres
pasó a segunda vuelta con 15.8% de los
votos y Bernardo Arévalo con el
11.8%, el tercero el partido vamos de
Alejandro yamatei tenía casi un 8%, es
decir hay una diferencia de casi 200.000
votos de el tercero del partido de
yamatei con el Arévalo que fue la gran
sorpresa entonces con esta decisión la
corte constitucional insta a que de
haber sido alterado los resultados pues
se hagan las modificaciones pertinentes
vamos a Estados Unidos porque esta
semana la Corte Suprema recordemos de
mayoría conservadora tomó una serie de
decisiones que recortan derechos a las
personas lgbt del país y a la población
afro estadounidense Laura él nos lo
cuenta
en tan solo dos días la Corte Suprema
tomó decisiones importantes para la
sociedad estadounidense y empezó con
sentencias que afectaron a los
estudiantes el jueves la Corte Suprema
dictaminó que la discriminación positiva
en las admisiones universitarias era
inconstitucional la derecha
estadounidense saludó el fallo como una
victoria para la meritocracia mientras
la izquierda destacó que esta decisión
no tomaba en cuenta las inequidades
étnicas y raciales
me preocupa que haga retroceder a
Estados Unidos que limite las
oportunidades de los estudiantes de
color y que limite los avances que hemos
visto en las últimas décadas
pero no fue el único golpe para los
estudiantes el viernes 6 de los nuevos
jueces declararon invalidó el plan del
gobierno de joeyda de kundonar
parcialmente la deuda estudiantil una
promesa que beneficiaría a unos 43
millones de estudiantes sabes lo que me
da miedo imagina que vas y obtienes tu
maestría imagina que obtienes incluso tu
doctorado entonces debes 180 mil dólares
tienes un doctorado y no puedes pagar
tus préstamos
otra población enfadada con las últimas
sentencias de la Corte Suprema es la
comunidad lgbtiq más el viernes el alto
tribunal también falló a favor de una
diseñadora de páginas web que citó sus
creencias cristianas para negarse a
trabajar con parejas del mismo sexo a
partir de ahora las empresas con valor
creativo pueden invocar su libertad de
expresión para no prestar un servicio
dentro de mí siento tristeza y me duele
pensar que hay gente ahí afuera que no
haría negocios conmigo por mi sexualidad
un año después de la anulación del
derecho al aborto esas tres sentencias
ilustrarán de nuevo los dos Campos que
existen entre los nueve jueces de la
Corte Suprema el reflejo de una sociedad
estadounidense dividida entre ideas
conservadoras y progresistas
en otras noticias Twitter volvió a
aprenderse por una decisión errática de
su dueño y lon musk anunció que limitará
el número de publicaciones diarias que
pueden ver los usuarios sin embargo los
detalles de la medida no están claros
una polémica más en el Twitter de elon
musk El controversial Magnate
sudafricano anunció a través de un tweet
que ha decidido limitar el número de
publicaciones diarias que pueden
visualizar los usuarios esta decisión se
debe a niveles extremos en la
recolección de datos personales por
agentes externos a la aplicación
las cuentas verificadas están limitadas
a leer 6000 publicaciones al día las
cuentas sin verificar a 600
publicaciones al día las nuevas cuentas
sin verificar a 300 publicaciones al día
está controversial decisión Del
multimillonario se une a la larga lista
de turbulencias en la dirigencia de
Twitter como la entrada de la
suscripción de pago Twitter Blue las
constantes caídas de los servidores y el
recorte masivo de personal sin embargo
la disminución en La regulación de
contenidos dentro de la aplicación es la
medida que ha polarizado más al internet
y podría entrar en conflicto con
normativas de organismos como la Unión
Europea
[Aplausos]
discursos de odio los actos de
terrorismo y muchas otras cosas que
vemos en redes sociales ya no serán
posibles
el anuncio de elon musk provocó una
oleada de críticas por parte de los
usuarios de la app lo que obligó a la
actual ceo de Twitter a extender el
límite de visualización a casi el doble
de lo anunciado originalmente
en Canadá este sábado miles de
trabajadores sindicados de la industria
portuaria se declararon en huelga la
movilización llega tras la imposibilidad
de alcanzar un nuevo convenio colectivo
para el sector y se espera que tenga un
importante impacto en la economía del
país de momento el paro se centra en la
Columbia británica y varias empresas
piden al gobierno que garantice las
actividades portuarias
vamos ahora a Venezuela porque las
autoridades ratificaron la
inhabilitación de María Corina Machado
quien hace perfilaba como una de las
favoritas decaradas primarias de la
oposición venezolana para elegir al
candidato que se enfrentará a Nicolás
Maduro en las elecciones de 2024
este voto la exdiputada anti chavista
María Corina Machado está inhabilitada
por 15 años para competir por un cargo
de elección popular así lo ratificó la
contraloría general de Venezuela la
decisión tendría que ver con el respaldo
de Machado a las sanciones impuestas por
Estados Unidos contra el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y su apoyo a Juan guaidó
La líder es hoy una de las favoritas de
Cara a las elecciones primarias de la
oposición
[Música]
[Aplausos]
inútil en administración que pretenden
pero la contraloría no es Clara sobre
desde y hasta cuándo rige la sanción en
2015 el mismo evento aplicó una sanción
por un año contra Machado cuando iba a
presentarse a las elecciones
parlamentarias a comienzos de 2023 la
oposición venezolana convocó a
elecciones el 22 de octubre para elegir
al candidato que enfrentaría a maduro en
las presidenciales de 2024 Machado
reafirmó su precandidatura y no será la
única que compita bajo una sanción
Enrique capriles y Freddy superlano
recibieron acciones similares en el
pasado
apéndice que es la contraloría del
estado que la usan como un un órgano
para perseguir para inhabilitar
Sencillamente todos están al margen de
la ley ninguno goza de legitimidad y de
este régimen que no busca más que en su
estado de pánico a callar la decisión de
un pueblo que ha decidido ser libre
Estados Unidos condenó la decisión de la
contraloría mientras que la oea aseguró
que el fallo es arbitrario y que el
gobierno de maduro utiliza los
mecanismos de inhabilidad para aferrarse
al poder
y cerramos en México con una noticia que
sin duda sale de lo habitual en las
informaciones que solemos darles Y es
que en un ritual tradicional el alcalde
de San Pedro guamelula en Oaxaca se casó
con un caimán el reptil de 7 años y de
nombre princesita representa la fuerza
de la naturaleza y la ceremonia
escenifica la unión entre la divinidad y
la humanidad el alcalde celebró el lazo
con besos el animal que con la boca
atada y vestido de novia fue adorado en
las calles de la ciudad con estas
imágenes Nos despedimos gracias por su
atención
[Música]